please welcome back Mohammed khande and
welcome Simon sinek
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
Simon Phoenix
oh this is going to be fun
as I told you yesterday I have no idea
what it's going to go but you know your
team told me that I had to say something
controversial
no
we don't
sorry Simon many
men in this room know who you are right
you're quite famous but uh let me
attribute to a brief intro of Simon so
Simon
you have studied 100 greatest leaders
are currently running the organization
organizations today and what behaviors
they display
you're also best-selling author right
start with why
Leaders Eat Last
together is better
and the infinite game four books huh
that's pretty good
okay
do you have another one coming or that's
it my publisher would like me to yeah
okay just asking so we have a lot of
things to talk about so listen for all
of you in the audience uh you can ask
questions to the PWC Live app okay so we
are going to just have a conversation
with Simon but any questions you might
have I'll try to uh to filter them and
you know and we go and
you know into a conversation and that's
how we do it and you'll see also in the
PWC Live app the last book that was
written by Simon the Anthony game you
can now order a free copy of that book
to the PWC Live app so everybody here
will have the benefit of wonderful I
didn't get a book from you so so Simon
let me give you a little bit of
background on PWC first before we get
into the questioning and the team that
you have here
so we are a people business
okay under all the folks that you have
here we have about 30 000 people
they are all leaders in this room
and we have 30 000 people that are not
here today that we have been given the
privilege to lead okay we are growing
very fast
we have a very diverse team we have
different practices that are represented
here but also we have
folks that come from outside that John
Peter received a couple of hundred of
them in this room during the pandemic
so imagine very diverse team growing
fast
putting different businesses together in
addition to that we have to constantly
reinvent ourselves
because of the not pressures but the
opportunities that we have in the market
with our clients today
so the need for reinvention is important
right so
it is going to be playing very good for
us to understand
what you mean by the Anthony game I know
you wrote that book
I watch a few videos also about the
infinite game but tell us what do you
mean by this infinite game
in the mid 1980s
philosopher and theologian by the name
of Dr James cars to find these two types
of games finite games and infinite games
a finite game is defined as known
players fixed rules and an agreed upon
objective football baseball there's
always a beginning middle and an end and
if there is a winner then necessarily
there have to be losers
then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are and new players can join at
any time
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible we are players in infinite
games every day of Our Lives whether we
know it or not there's no such thing as
winning education
you can come in first for the finite
amount of time you're at school where we
agree upon the time frame and the
metrics grades but nobody wins education
and though we can keep learning for our
whole lives nobody wins Health Care
nobody wins global politics and there's
definitely no such thing as winning
business
but if we listen to the language of so
many leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't actually know the game
that they're playing in they talk about
being number one or being the best or
beating their competition oh we said
that too yeah
but okay but the question is the
question is the question is based on
what
based upon what agreed upon objectives
metrics and time frames clearly
your competitors the other players in
the game haven't agreed to your metrics
time frames uh or you know or objectives
nobody's agreed what winning looks like
you know and so this is a problem
because when we play with a finite
mindset in an infinite game when we play
to win in a game that has no Finish Line
uh there are some very predictable and
consistent outcomes the big ones are the
decline of trust the decline of
cooperation and actually the decline of
innovation
and so there's a great irony
in companies that are trying to reinvent
themselves and stay ahead of the curve
while Simon simultaneously trying to
beat their competition and win and be
the best those two are incongruent right
um uh I'll give you an example a silly
example
um when Circuit City went bankrupt Best
Buy didn't win anything
right it didn't win anything there's
nothing their number one competitor fell
out of the game because they ran out of
the will and resources to play but Best
Buy didn't win anything they had to keep
playing in fact with the rise of Amazon
the entire rules of how they played the
game had to change and so the reality is
is when you play with an infinite
mindset you play Not To Beat anyone but
ultimately you play uh the only true
competitor is yourself which is how do
we make our products better this year
than what they were last year how do we
make our services better this year than
they were last year how do we make our
culture stronger this year than it was
last year and it's a game of constant
constant Improvement but there's no such
thing as winning
but you mentioned five attributes right
of yeah
creating that infinite mindset because
I'm sure that is something that we have
to practice Yeah right what are the five
attributes so
you so to to convert to an infinite
mindset or Embrace an infinite mindset
as you said there are five uh there are
five practices uh number one is you have
to uh Advance adjust cause
the second one is build trusting teams
uh the third is study your worthy Rivals
your fourth is have a capacity for
existential flexibility and the final
one is to
um uh have the courage to lead
so really quickly
um you know a lot of companies have
vision statements or mission statements
and they
usually sound similar and they're not
helpful to be the best damn to be the
most respected the most preeminent blah
blah blah the highest value for our
clients blah blah blah can you can you
shut down the monitors please
shut them the slides you know
[Laughter]
it's very nice being here thank you very
much
um and it's not wrong it's just not
useful like nobody nobody
oh man no I mean
like I mean no one no one in your
practice
a total of zero
is waking up every morning and thinking
to themselves today's the day like I'm
gonna Advance the mission right it's he
said that yesterday
laughs
so when I talk about advancing a Just
Cause right
um a just cause is something a lot more
idealistic it's a statement of the world
that you wish that the the way the world
you wished it worked the it's a world
that you imagine like we imagine a world
that's PWC we imagine a world in which
and then we devote our practice we
devote our energy we devote our
resources to advance towards that cause
and we're going to bring our clients
with us the work that we do takes us
closer to that course so I'll give you
an example so my just cause our
organizations just cause we imagine a
world so you can see there's that
Forward Thinking which as an aside which
is why we call it vision is because you
have to be able to see it right so we
imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do that is our cause that
is a cause so just that we would be
willing to sacrifice in order to advance
closer towards that ideal we will never
get there it is an ideal okay and you
can look at organizations or leaders
that have made profound impact in their
Industries or in the world you'll see
these just causes whether it's all men
are created equal right it's a just
cause imperfect in all in its own way
but you can see a nation striving
um I have a dream literally imagining
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with little
white children imperfect in its own uh
in in reality but you can see a a nation
striving
um when Apple and Steve Jobs used to
talk about empowering individuals to
stand up to Big Brother you can see the
attraction to the personal computer
because it literally gives power to an
individual to compete against a
corporation imperfect but a striving and
all of these things become striving that
become incredibly inspiring for for a
Workforce because they feel like they're
contributing to something bigger than
themselves but when you think about
innovation
if you say provide greater value for our
clients
and it's not wrong I have to stress it's
not wrong
but but
when you say innovate around that The
Innovation tends to be more features and
benefits it tends to be tweaking and
efficiencies when you say be the best I
don't even know how you innovate around
that right you can't say some to say
somebody
you know make innovate so but when you
say innovate a way to advance this the
ideas can come from anywhere inside the
organization and the ideas tend to be a
lot bigger okay so it's not that those
things are wrong that what I'm what I'm
offering are what a a clearer path to
embracing an infinite mindset okay right
it's not that the other doesn't work it
doesn't have value it just has less
value in the infinite game okay right so
that was the first one just go just
cause advancing or just advancing you'll
never achieve it it's an idealized State
and even when you hear me say it when
you hear people sit it sort of feels
like it has more gravitas and it's
proprietary you know it doesn't sound
like every other company's mission
statement okay
um uh then I talk about building
trusting teams which is essential
um because especially when you're
operating at scale 300 000 people trust
is absolutely essential senior
leadership has to trust uh middle
management that has to trust the front
line that that they not only understand
what we're here to do but I don't have
to micromanage you right one of my
favorite examples of what a trusting
team looks like it happened a few years
ago when I was on a business trip I went
to Las Vegas and they were very nice to
put me up at the Four Seasons out there
are you sure about business yeah it's a
lovely Hotel
um just asking what's that it was for
business right it was for business yes
it was it a real business trip
um and uh
they happen to have a coffee bar in the
lobby of the Four Seasons in Vegas and
so one afternoon I went and bought
myself a cup of coffee and the Barista
working that day was a kid named Noah
Noah was funny and charming and engaging
and I spent far too long buying a cup of
coffee because I just so enjoyed talking
to Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah
um do you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant like is rational I
like the people I like the I like the
work you know I get paid well I like my
job love is emotional it's a higher
order connection right like do you love
your wife I like her a lot right
hahaha
it's clearly
clearly a different standard right so
when Noah said I love my job my ears
perked up this kid has an emotional
connection to his work so immediately I
followed up and said tell me
specifically what the Four Seasons is
doing that you would say to me you love
your job
and again without skipping a beat Noah
said throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me how I'm doing
ask me if there's anything that I need
to do my job better not just my manager
any manager and then he said I also work
at another hotel
and there the managers walked past us
and catch us when we do something wrong
they're the managers are always trying
to drive performance and make sure we
hit our numbers he said there I'd like
to keep my head below the radar get
through the day and just collect my
paycheck only at the Four Seasons do I
feel I can be myself
now this is the exact same human being
working at two different companies and
yet our experience of him will be
profoundly different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works you know I
get this question all the time you know
Simon how do we get the most out of our
people people are not a towel that you
ring them out to see how much you can
get out of them
you know it's it's a it's it's it's it's
that's a good one right
it's a flawed question the question is
how do we create an environment on in
which our people can work at their
natural best and that is the art of
leadership it's creating environment in
which relationships can thrive in which
trust can Thrive and we all know what it
feels like to be on a trusting team
right
um it means that we feel psychologically
safe enough
to raise our hand and say
um I made a mistake
or I need help
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared or I don't know what to do
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us unfortunately we also all know what
it feels like not to work on a trusting
team where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
we force our people to come to work and
lie hide and fake where they're
pretending that they've made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about Innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas and you have to
create an environment which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to best or significant Improvement so
this is this is absolutely essential if
you want to play in the infinite game
because ultimately every single person
here will leave the organization or die
at some point you know uh circle of life
and you'll be replaced by new people and
so the opportunity is to create a
company with vision and teams that can
Thrive and Outlast every single person
here and that is part of the
responsibility of leadership is to leave
the organization in better shape than
you found it which means grooming the
Next Generation like one of the primary
responsibilities of any leader is to
make more leaders and so building
trusting teams is absolute is absolutely
core to that I find the worthy rival one
studying where the arrivals is actually
the easiest one to embrace and Implement
and I find it kind of fascinating as
well in business we talk about having
competitors who are your competitors the
problem is is that notion of competition
is a very finite mindset because
competitors are there to be beaten right
you beat your competitors in baseball
but in the infinite game there are no
competitors there's other players for
sure
um but unlike in football or baseball in
an infinite game
you can have two companies that offer
relatively the same set of services for
you know relatively the same price
relatively the same quality and you know
a plus and minus here and there and both
can do profoundly well make tons of
money at the exact same time right in
other words there's no winning or losing
and so this is why we talk about being
the best based on what
um and so to to try and beat our
competition what we're doing is we're
spending too much time focusing on what
they're doing and not enough time
focusing on what we're doing
and so rather to embrace this concept of
of worthy rivalry where you view all the
other players in your industry as Rivals
and some of them are worthy of
comparison in other words there are
other players in your industry other
players in the game who do one or many
things better than you
respect that and admire that because
their strengths reveal to you reveal to
you your weaknesses and if the if the
true only true competitor in the
infinite game is yourself then knowing
where your weaknesses are is essential
because then you can improve upon them
and so ask yourselves like who are the
other players who when their name comes
up it actually makes you insecure angry
it's probably because they're doing
something better you know is their
leadership better is their sales team
better you know whatever it is their
implementation better what new is their
marketing better and instead of trying
to beat them or get angry respect them
learn from them and then go apply the
lessons to yourself a game of constant
Improvement you can do it tomorrow and
by the way your worthy Rivals can change
out because sometimes they're no longer
worthy of comparison anymore
uh because they've screwed up their own
business for whatever reason too much
finite mindset I guess
um uh yeah so you know we had a
conversation yesterday with everybody
around
who our competitors are today yeah and
about not fearing our competitors right
because to your point be grateful for
them yeah be grateful for them sure no
let's not fear them but also
understanding that whoever we assume we
are competing against today
might not be
who will be competing against tomorrow
right because you always have new
players coming to the game that's what
you're saying well this is the great
irony in business
because the the funny thing is the
competitors that you select it's an
arbitrary list right because no none of
the big competitors of the companies
that take you down like
Myspace didn't even know Facebook
existed you know uh you know all the
publishing houses
didn't they ignored Amazon they turned
down investing in Amazon you know all
the movie companies and all the
television stations thought Netflix was
cute
right they were NBC CBS and ABC and fox
were so focused on each other they
literally were ignorant so the threats
coming from outside and it's because old
thinking with old players and again it's
only because they're doing what's
familiar you're taking somebody who's a
senior executive at a company who's come
up through an industry who's been doing
the same thing for 20 or 30 years and
now you're going to say
stop all of that
there's new ways of thinking I need you
to completely unlearn everything and
it's not that that can't be done
but as human beings we say to ourselves
well what I've been doing has worked
perfectly fine for 30 years I think I
know what I'm doing I'm okay thanks very
much and that's dangerous
and um I mean Netflix is such a great
example because
the then CEO of Blockbuster remember
them
and Blockbuster was the 800 pound
gorilla I mean it was the only
significant uh National video rental
chain in the country right
huge company
um and we knew this new technology
called streaming was available and it
wasn't quite good enough yet which is
why Netflix was experimenting with a new
pricing model if you remember it was
subscription and you could get the DVDs
keep them for as long as you want send
it back and then they'd replace them and
then eventually they knew they knew
eventually that would become streaming
and the CEO back then uh saw that this
was significant and he went to the board
and said I think we should experiment
with a subscription model and the board
would not allow him to make that change
you want another reason
because 12 of their revenues came from
late fees
oh wow
and they were too afraid to lose 12 of
their revenues so instead they lost the
whole company
and that's the problem which is
sometimes you have to take a short-term
hit to innovate especially when it comes
with experimenting with new models and
the joke was it wasn't an experiment
because another company had already
proved that it had validity was working
that's the Folly the Folly was there was
no risk they were just short term
uh finite thinkers that were thinking
about the the all they could think about
was losing that 12 percent
now the whole company is down
and now it doesn't exist and Netflix is
literally redefining the category and I
did not invest in Blockbuster
so you talked about how do you call it
uh organizational flexibility right or
agility oh the existential flexibility
existential flexibility okay existential
flexibility is not like the normal
flexibility the day-to-day that you need
to do work it is
um it is a a business's ability to make
profound
180 degree strategic shift in order to
advance that just cause
um I think one of the single best
examples of what an existential Flex
looks like happened back in the late 70s
early 80s so I mentioned apple and Steve
Jobs Steve Jobs had this vision of
empowering individuals to stand up to
Big Brother
he saw the personal computer is the
perfect technology to do that
um and uh the jobs in apple had was
already a big company ready fast growing
company one of the first unicorns
um they'd already had success from the
Apple One the Apple II jobs was already
famous and as is the practice of a lot
of Executives they went and visited
other companies and jobs and a few of
his senior guys went on a tour of Xerox
Park out in Menlo Park and Xerox showed
them a new technology that they had
invented called the graphic user
interface
which allowed people to use a computer
by clicking on a mouse and moving a
cursor across a desktop
and jobs looked at this new technology
that they didn't invent and said this is
profound because right now if you want
to use a computer you have to learn how
to you know you have to learn a basic
code right which means a very small
percentage of the population can
actually use it and if my ambition is to
empower as many individuals as possible
then this graphic user interface is
something I have no choice to advance my
cause it's obvious that we have to
invest in it and so he said to his
senior Executives who were with him
we're going to invest in this graphic
user interface thing and one of them
let's call him the voice of reason
uh said Steve we can't we we cannot
invest in this we've already invested
millions of dollars and countless
man-hours on a completely different
strategic Direction uh if we take that
money away and reinvest it in this
graphic user interface thing we're going
to blow up our own business
to which jobs actually said
better we should blow it up than someone
else
and that decision led to the Macintosh
the Macintosh so profoundly changed the
course of computing that the entire
software of Windows is designed to act
like a Macintosh and the reason a
computer is now a household appliance
uh is because of that decision
um and they did take a short-term loss
and they did take a hit
um because that's what happens
necessarily when you reinvest
um but that's an existential Flex
profound strategic shift in order to
advance your cause and you know the
funny thing was with covet a lot of
companies were forced to do it in most
in most careers you'll do it once two at
the absolute most but most most people
go through their careers without having
to make an existential Flex it's a
pretty significant shift and it causes a
lot of pain and stress to the
organization which is why you need
trusting teams and why you need to just
cause because if you have a just cause
this shift is like of course we have to
make this change and if you have
trusting teams they go all right this is
going to suck but we're on board
and if you don't have the just cause you
don't have the the trusting teams you'll
you'll probably break the company
well I'm thinking at this time what this
would mean for us but I don't know I
well I mean no this is good thinking by
the way because listen none of us have
the answers here about what the future
is going to be of course type of pivot
what what it might be for us in the
future now that's the thing that we need
to think about well I mean so there's
some there are some Clues
um uh
David Marquez work talks about this
where he talks about the people at the
top of the organization have all the
authority but the people at the bottom
have all the information you know it's a
lot of your Frontline staff who are
day-to-day with your clients and it's
the people at the top who aren't
day-to-day with the clients but they're
making all the Strategic uh decisions
and so it's not about
um necessarily pushing all the
information up but sometimes it's about
pushing Authority down however there's
another component to that which is when
you have your brainstormings are you
actually asking your team what they're
seeing are you bringing in junior people
and if you go to your middle managers
and you say who are your Hot Shots you
know who's the 25 year old 27 year old
who's just like blowing like just
blowing everybody's mind smart like you
they know who they are
grab them borrow them bring them in and
say tell me what you're thinking tell me
what you're saying now it doesn't mean
you do what they say but you're going to
get information and you're going to get
a quality of idea that for good reasons
and bad reasons that have that the
senior folks just don't have that
perspective they don't have the
perspective of Frontline they haven't
been there in a long time and they also
don't have the perspective of of Youth
and new technology so so reinvention all
the ideas on what you could do and what
you could become exist in your business
the question is are you inviting the
people to contribute some of those ideas
no great Point great fun let people
don't know to the concept of trust that
you mentioned yeah I mentioned to you we
are very diverse team
many of us in this room are new
colleagues yep because we are just
getting to work together yeah we haven't
done anything uh a lot because it's a
new organization that we build together
we are growing very fast we have
newcomers coming from uh competitors
okay other players other players okay
yeah I learned something today yeah
it's good that's good other players so
what are you seeing out there about
some of the best practices around
building trust in organizations that are
so diverse
and so so fast growing like so so trust
in a company is not that dissimilar from
trust in our personal relationships and
and friendships you know it's a human
experience
um it's a Feeling
um uh and as we've all experienced
during covid it's more difficult to
build trust uh virtually it's not
impossible but it requires a lot more
work and a lot more intention you know
Isaac Stern the famous violinist
said music is what happens between the
notes well trust is what happens between
the meetings right it's the conversation
walking into the meeting and the
conversation walking out of the meeting
it's the bumping into somebody in the
hallway and being like Oh I meant to
tell you you know it's the hey you want
to grab a coffee that over the course of
time those those little moments of Truth
those little innocuous experiences that
by themselves count for zero but over
time they start to build relationship
and they start to build trust the hard
thing in a virtual environment
um is those things are gone you don't
have between the meetings you only have
the meeting yeah and so what you have to
do is create those opportunities
artificially right prescriptively you
have to force it to happen so one easy
thing to do we even we've embraced in
our company is a Monday morning huddle
where you know it's encouraged that as
many people show up as possible of
course if you have client stuff you go
do that but as many people on an
operating team come together and uh and
just check in with each other and it's
not about work there's zero discussion
of work it's what's on your heart and
mind
and then we answer a funny or
provocative question that whoever's
leading huddle that month will will pose
to the team and it's an opportunity for
us to connect as human beings where we
say this weekend was a hard weekend you
know my dad was admitted to hospital or
this weekend was a great weekend because
I got to spend some time with the kids I
didn't even know you had kids and we get
to see each other as human beings
um and it's it goes a long way it's it
seems small and silly but over the
course of time we start to learn about
each other and see each other as people
rather than just as as co-workers and
you know or encouraging people to have
work sessions with each other where you
turn on FaceTime or Zoom or something
and although you're not having a meeting
you just have them there while you're
doing your work or having drinks
together or you know I'm a huge fan of
using the telephone because I actually
think you can connect even better over
the telephone than than sometimes over
Zoom
um and like if you have an issue instead
of sending an email pick up the phone
and call somebody because very often
you'll solve the problem quicker and
it's not 55 backwards and forwards but
you'll probably learn something new and
you can hear it tone of voice which is
all goes to building relationships so uh
we already know how to do it it's just a
matter of doing it and and in the real
world when you talk about diverse teams
and new teams you know it's great
leaders have the have the patience to
sort of have a little empathy ask
somebody how are you learn something
about them were you from how do you find
yourself here what's your career path
it's it's human stuff it's human stuff
it's just doing it at work that's now
thank you that's pretty good so you know
we talk about trust
let's talk about teaming building high
performance teams okay what are you
seeing out there about some of the best
practices around teaming and
collaboration we are an organization
that the only shot we have in the market
if we all work together right because as
individuals
when we look at many of the other
players yeah they also have good people
yeah or Secret Sauce you hired some of
them yes we hired some of them yes we
did there's good people everywhere I
mean that's the reality right but then
the our secret sauce yeah we believe is
teaming and collaboration because it
gives us the ability
to solve problems in a way that is
unique and differentiated to get to
outcomes to get to Solutions
much better yeah I think that's
partially true
and uh
no no no no no no it's okay no no you're
absolutely my bubble just like poof no
no no I didn't say it was wrong
it's what I think that's partially true
which is teams are essential trust is
essential the the teaming the ability to
come to Solutions is essential but if
you take a group of people and put them
in a team even if they get along and you
have some decent leadership and there's
no sense of purpose or cause or just
cause to give them to advance then what
it does is it creates it's it's you you
can get myopic and so if you take a
great team and you give them something
to strive towards that's when you're
going to get those really big wonderful
ideas so I think you're 100 right which
is you've got to have those teams
they're essential but that give then
then give that team
um uh make them feel that their work is
is worth more than the money you you
make from it right that that it's having
impact in the world or in your clients
businesses
um that is that when we look back at our
careers and say that was a life worth
living you know
um so I I think it is definitely part of
it and and we're in San Diego and just
across the bay you have Coronado
in Coronado is the home of the Navy
Seals
I've had a chance to visit Coronado and
visit with the Navy Seals and uh I had
the opportunity within the seals there
is a more Elite group
they have video games named after them
they have number the number six in their
name which is technically a secret so we
kind of talk about it
but the development group but SEAL Team
Six yep Dev crew the dev group is uh is
an elite team within within the seals I
had the opportunity to work with and get
to know the head of training for Dev
group for SEAL Team Six and I asked him
how do you choose who gets into this
group I mean they're all incredibly High
performers
and he drew a chart an x y axis and on
the vertical axis he wrote the word for
performance and on the horizontal axis
he wrote the word trust
um and the way he defined it is
performance is how good are you at your
job trust is what's your character what
kind of person are you and the way he
put it is I may trust you with my life
but do I trust you with my money or my
wife right there's seals
um
and the what he explained
say that one again yeah
I may trust you with my life by do I do
I trust you with my money or my wife so
you might be great on the battlefield
you might have a you might have good aim
but like do I trust you off the
battlefield and so that you may trust
somebody to do good work with a client
but do you want to spend six hours with
them stranded at an airport waiting for
a flight yeah it's a different app it's
a different that's what I understand
yeah
yeah thank you yeah oh yeah I'll
translate
why right yeah so
um as he explained it to me
uh clearly nobody wants this person the
low performer of low Trust of course
clearly everybody wants this person the
high performer of high Trust of course
what they learned is that this person
over here the high performer of low
trust is a toxic team member and they
would rather have a medium performer of
high trust sometimes even a low
performer of high trust it's a relative
scale over
the high performer of low trust and if
you think about most businesses we have
a million metrics to measure someone's
performance and we have negligible to no
metrics to measure someone's
trustworthiness and I think this is a
huge opportunity for you as a business
quite frankly which is if you can
develop
objective metrics
that you can help companies Implement
you will profoundly change the course of
business right because it's not that
companies aren't interested in it they
just don't know how to measure it right
there is an irony which is actually very
easy to identify the the these high
performers of low trust if you just go
to any team and ask them who the
is they'll point to the same person
uh
laughs
and by the way equally so if you go to
any team and you say who's always got
your back when the chips are down you
know they're always there for you
they'll also all point to the same
person who's probably your most gifted
natural leader who may not be your your
your highest performing individual uh
you're hyper it may not be a high
performing individual on the team but
they get they get more out of the rest
of the team so uh that's interesting I
don't think that there is any metrics
that we know about no there's not very
much I mean they exist but they're not
very good and they're not they're not
easily comparable or or objectified and
and the military knows how to do this I
mean the military is actually much
better at measuring trust because uh for
them it's trust is life and death right
that if you don't and I've had so many
experiences getting to work with Marines
or SEALS or whoever where the way they
talk about trust
um I'll give you a a another example
just to so I had the opportunity to
visit Quantico which is where the Marine
Corps selects its office
and I had a briefing by the colonel in
charge of of of OCS officer candidates
school
um and he showed up late for the
briefing now Marines don't show up late
you know if you're on time you're late
that's their belief and um uh and he
showed up late he said I'm terribly
sorry we've had an incident on base
that we're considering throwing out one
of our students ending their career
throwing them out of the Marine Corps
and of course Curious George here is
like what happened you know and he said
to me um
he fell asleep on watch
and I said
that's it
like he fell asleep on watch in the
woods of Virginia and you're going to
throw him out of the Marine Corps
and he I like you guys are pretty tough
he said no you don't understand he said
when we asked him about it he denied it
when we asked him about it again he
denied it again and when we gave him
irrefutable proof
then he said I want to take
responsibility for my actions and the
problem we have is you take
responsibility for your actions at the
time you perform your actions not at the
time you get caught
he said we had another Marine who fell
asleep on watch he owned up to it
immediately we punished him and we have
no problem with him
and then the colonel went on to explain
to me says you have to understand if I
take this person and I put them in a
leadership position
and if his Marines doubt for one second
that their leader is being honest with
them
or if if his Marines think that he's
doing something just to advance his own
career
and protect himself with the sacrifices
of his Marines trust will break and
people will die
and so when in a combat situation when
there is chaos and by the way command
and control is not as not a leadership
uh um
mentality or philosophy that you can
engage on a regular basis and it's not
so in the military but it is essential
in chaos covet is a great example like
when we went into covid that was chaos
every plan went haywire everything went
haywire and you do need leadership that
does actually go into command and
control but the thing is that command
and control only works when you have
spent time building the trust up until
that moment because when I tell you to
follow my orders blindly
don't question me just do it there has
to be the undying belief that you're
making this decision for the right
reason and you're not going to
needlessly sacrifice me and I know that
you will make mistakes so the Marines
know that mistakes will get made and
people will die because of those
mistakes but we're not doing them on
purpose and we're not needlessly
sacrificing people and they will follow
those orders blindly now that's an
extreme example because it's the Marine
Corps and it's life and death but the
same is true in business which is you
can come out and control all the time
that's micromanagement and that wears
people out but but good leaders who are
empathetic and spend the time building
trust and care about their people in
chaos
in crisis they have the opportunity to
convert into in into short-term command
and control and it's highly highly
effective and the team comes together in
remarkable remarkable ways but the trust
has to be built first you know we have
one of our colleagues in the audience
who knows command control Sean Joyce
where are you
he knows command and control because it
was a deputy director of the FBI and
also he was part of Hostage rescue so he
knows yeah he knows about it yeah he
doesn't listen to me yeah ever
what's up with that we need to talk Sean
okay so uh so tell us about the no the
whole thing about teaming and metrics
what gets in the way of good teaming
what have you seen out there
what gets in the way of good teaming why
I don't think it's you know I think it's
the stuff that you'd expect I mean I
think it's Egos and insecurities I mean
we're human beings and I think we forget
that I you know that that business is a
very human Enterprise I mean it's called
a company for heaven's sakes I mean it's
literally a collection of people
um and you know um
passive aggression and you know I've
seen this in other companies where
everybody's so nice but there's no
healthy uh there's no healthy mechanism
to release tension or have a fight or
have a disagreement and I think one of
the big challenges that modern business
faces quite frankly is we want good
leadership but we don't teach people how
to lead you know when someone's Junior
in their career we give them tons of
training to be good at their job some
people get Advanced degrees you know
mbas or accountants you know lawyers
they get Advanced degrees to be good at
their jobs and when you get somebody
who's new you give them you know
training and you'll let them Apprentice
with someone and Shadow with somebody
more experienced and we give them huge
amount of patience to learn what it's
like to be at this company why because
we want them to be good at the job and
if they're really good
they'll get promoted and eventually they
get promoted to a position where they're
now responsible for the people who do
the job they used to do but most
companies are very bad at giving those
people any training for their new job
which is called leadership right and the
reality is we have to make this
conversion where we're no longer
responsible for the job we're now
responsible for the people who perform
the job and it's a different skill set
and the other problem is is
because you're good at what you do you
know you actually do want to tell people
how to do their job because you actually
are better at their job that's what got
you promoted but probably that's not
your job anymore
and so there's a huge gap in the market
again fill this Gap you'll have a
profound impact
on the business world as we know it
because companies are dying
we don't teach
active listening
we don't teach how to give and receive
feedback
we don't teach empathy
we don't teach how to have an effective
confrontation we don't teach how to have
a difficult conversation
and we saw the lack of the skill set
really show up you see it happen in more
extreme circumstances but it's available
all the time but after the murder of
George Floyd it's a great example after
the murder of George Floyd
there is a lot of leaders who did
nothing
it's not because they're bad people
it's because they didn't know how to
have a difficult conversation about race
with their team
and they were so afraid of triggering
someone or inflaming a situation or
saying the wrong thing that they opted
to do nothing right that's a skill set
that isn't and we can teach that skill
set
and it's it's it's and it's it's not
necessarily difficult it just requires
practice so for example I need to have a
difficult conversation with you what did
you say I I like I need to have a
difficult conversation with you I don't
want to have this a conversation because
I'm afraid that I'm going to say the
wrong thing I'm afraid that I may uh
trigger you but I think it's more
important for us to have this
conversation than not have this
conversation so I'm going to need your
help as we Wade through this together
that's how you start a difficult
conversation
and so I think there's a massive Market
opportunity to teach the skills of
leadership to people who are becoming
leaders because if we want good leaders
we have to teach them how to lead as a
skill like any other
wow okay no this is good good
I was watching one of your videos around
goal setting and performance
measurements when you look at the trend
lines not looking at oh right yeah
specific so tell us more about your your
views around goal setting performance
evaluation how do you look at high
performance so
um this is sort of when you learn to
embrace an infinite mindset and remember
business is an infinite game there's no
winning business so to ignore it is to
literally play with the wrong mindset
for the actual game you're in so the
more one learns to embrace an infinite
mindset the more you start to see
opportunities for the way that we run
our businesses so for example goal
setting is a great one
um there's nothing wrong with setting
goals human beings need goals we're very
visually driven animals we need metrics
it's like you can't run a marathon
without mile markers it's actually
unnerving right we need to know how fast
and how far and that's what good metrics
do they tell us how fast our company is
going and how how far we've gone
but metrics need to be dials rather than
absolutes right so for example
um goal if you're a retail establishment
for example goal we want to open uh 200
stores
next year
right great
and the problem is is you're hiring so
quickly
and you're not spending enough time
training because you've got to hit that
200 store goal that you end up having
um a poor customer experience in most of
the stores and so they they'll
underperformer do badly and so when you
realize that you're hiring too quickly
and you're not training properly is it
more important to hit the 200 goal or is
it more important to dial it down and
say let's open 30 stores we
overestimated because let's be honest
most of our goals are arbitrary a bunch
of people sit in the room and go
wouldn't be great if we did 200 stores
this year and that's the corporate goal
you know
um
and worse and worse and worse
and worse we'll incentivize everybody to
hit that number you know
okay I need to make sure to say
something by the way they're clapping we
are not changing the forecast okay
all right they're saying so there's
nothing wrong with goal setting goal
setting is great people like ambition we
like difficult goals we like we like I
believe in overestimating capabilities
but I also believe in tracking what's
going on as you're driving towards that
goal and if you're breaking the thing as
you're going to hit the goal okay
congratulations you hit 200 stories and
you bonus everybody who's responsible
for that but you end up with 200 broken
stores and when you think about the
infinite game if the goal is to stay in
the game as long as possible that's not
a good strategy and so it's okay simply
dial it back and do it right
right and you're more likely to stay in
the game longer so that's one thing the
other thing is I think Trend data is
really important you know I we've over
indexed and you and I were talking about
this backstage
in the United States especially but the
rest of the world has kind of followed
along we over indexed on rugged
individualism we over indexed on uh
short-termism and we over indexed on
heroizing Jack Welch and GE right and if
you look at some of the things that came
out of the 80s and 90s and early 2000s
you know the rise of shareholder
Supremacy wasn't really a thing prior to
the late 70s right it was really
popularized in the 80s and 90s the rise
of incentivizing executive based on the
price of inequity rather than the
performance of the company wasn't really
a thing using mass layoffs to balance
the books just think about that for a
second I'm going to tell you that you no
longer have a job go home and tell your
family that you're that you've lost your
job not because you did anything wrong
it's not a meritocracy you've been a
great employee for 20 years but we
missed our arbitrary projections we're
still profitable just not as profitable
as we promised so I need you to
sacrifice so I can tell someone else we
made our numbers that philosophy which
is normal in business today so no normal
that CEOs go on television and talk
about oh we just announced layoffs to
meet our numbers and everybody goes you
know
and the stock price goes up figure that
one out but when and when we announced
increased spending on R D stock price
goes down figure that one out
um but I digress
um
uh the point is the point is is that
um uh uh that did not exist in the
United States prior to the 1980s it
actually didn't exist
and these philosophies of business that
are very very short-termism
and very very finite minded we're
popularized
in the 80s 90s and 2000s
and I think we're seeing a shift now
we're seeing a Young Generation that's
scratching their heads and saying is
that really what we want you know
companies companies uh complain about
how their Young Generation these young
kids aren't loyal and they State you
know and they quit and they leave and
they're not lo you know this is but
think about how they grow up they grew
up watching their parents get laid off
through no fault of their own why should
they trust companies right and so and I
and so I think we have a massive
opportunity
um to reinvent the way in which business
works and to to
push aside some of the things that you
know Jack Welch built a company for the
short term GE is a shadow of its former
self who knows if it's even going to
survive it'll get chopped up and sold
off for spare parts right
um
it wasn't a company built to last
ironically and I think there's a massive
opportunity and there's a massive vacuum
right now there used to be a time where
GE was the leadership Factory that if
you had GE on your resume you could go
run any company you wanted and drill it
into the ground it happened actually
yeah it did happen I mean it was the
leadership Factory I mean and and the GE
way and Jack Welch way was the standard
and since that's gone out of favor
because we realized it was good for the
short term not good for the long term
it's what what it was proved to be and
did a lot of damage to our economy along
the way and a lot of damage to corporate
cultures along the way you know the
average lifespan of a company used to be
60 years now it's 17.
um uh there is a massive gaping hole
that there is no leadership factory in
America right now there is no company
that is the gold standard for what
leadership should look like in a modern
new economy
it's not GE that's for sure you know
tech companies steal from each other but
there's no leadership Factory so my
challenge to you is why not you like why
not why not PWC that
why not you that you develop a style of
leadership and a curriculum of
leadership that you have a leadership
program that's simply having worked at
PWC literally when you apply for a new
job somewhere else like literally just
having PWC on your resume makes you the
number one candidate
to run another company
and imagine what happens when you create
a leadership Factory that your best
people
even your mediocre people because
they're so much better than everybody
else
go on to run the future of American
Business which is what happened in tge
which is why that model perpetuated
imagine the impact that you can have in
the future of business simply because
you embrace it for yourself you know I
didn't see this one coming I like it a
lot
that's
what I'm talking about yeah I had to
make up for accidentally sitting on your
vision statement
it's right there in front of you
laughs
[Laughter]
so the first book that you wrote yeah
was start with why right so actually a
colleague in this room gave me the book
you know many years ago so why did you
write a book and
what are some of the key takeaways from
that book
so start with why I wasn't supposed to
be a book and it wasn't supposed to be a
TED Talk it was born out of my own pain
my own journey
I had what appeared to be a
superficially good life I was living the
American dream I started my own business
I had a little marketing consultancy we
did good work we had great clients
um well-liked you know things were fine
but I completely fell out of love with
my own work
and people gave me stupid advice like do
what you love I'm like I'm doing the
same thing and I don't love it anymore
you know follow your bliss thank you
um
it's perfectly true it's just not
actionable
um and so I was very embarrassed by the
fact that I didn't want to wake up and
go to work anymore because superficially
everything was okay so I didn't talk
about it and all of my energy went into
pretending
that I was happier more successful and
More in control than I felt
and that is exhausting
and uh it wasn't until a dear friend of
mine came to me and said something's
wrong that I did I come clean
um and explained her what I was going
through and it lifted a huge weight off
my shoulders
and all of that energy that was going
into lying hiding and faking I
redirected and finding a solution to
ReDiscover my own passion and there was
a Confluence of events and I'll spare
you the Gory details but there was a
Confluence of events and I made this
discovery based on the biology of human
decision making that every single one of
us knows what we do you know the
products you sell you know the job you
do some of us know how we do it call it
your unique selling proposition or the
things that you think are your strengths
but very few of us can clearly
articulate whether corporately or
personally very few of us can clearly
articulate why we do what we do what's
your purpose cause or belief that under
underlies everything I knew what I did I
knew how I was better than everybody
else but I couldn't tell you why I was
doing it and I realized that missing
piece was the source of my malaise I
became obsessed with understanding my
why and the most important thing was I
learned how to help other people find
theirs and I just started helping my
friends and my friends started making
profound profound life changes and they
would invite me to talk about it with
their friends I would literally stand in
someone's living room and talk about
this thing called the Y and I would help
people find their why for 100 bucks on
the side
true
story
um and people just kept inviting me to
talk about it and I just kept saying yes
and somebody said you should write a
book and I shrug my shoulders and said
okay and before you knew it it sort of
became a thing and I think the reason
that both the Ted Talk and the book
gained such uh sort of organic
popularity because it was driven not by
marketing it was driven by people saying
you should read this or you should watch
this it's completely organic
um uh is because I think it resonates I
think it's a deeply human thing it
wasn't designed to be to fill some
Market opportunity it was it was
something that was deeply deeply
personal to me and remained so and do
takeaways where you need to start to
understand you need to know why you do
what you do and have that be the
foundation for everything that you do
whether as an individual or as an
organization yeah
you know it's funny because
when we thought about this this event
today
my team actually asked me
that question what's your why what's my
why yeah and
why are you asking
no and by the way it's it's a it's a
very difficult question to answer not
because we don't know it
it's because it and this is the biology
of it it exists in the part of the brain
that doesn't control language you know
our neocortex which is our Homo Sapien
brain is responsible for all of our
rational and analytical thought and
language but it's our limbic brain
that's sort of old mammalian brain which
is responsible for all of our feelings
it's also responsible for all of our
decision making but it has no capacity
for language that's why we have gut
decisions I know all the advice I'm
getting tells me to do X but it doesn't
feel right I think I'm going to do why
and you ask all the most successful
leaders or entrepreneurs you know what's
your what's your secret they'll all say
the same thing I trusted my gut now
there's no part of your stomach that
makes decisions
what they're attempting to say is I
couldn't put it into words but I could
feel and and so we have a sense of our
why and if you have the confidence to
trust your gut it goes you know we've
all done it we've all ignored and we've
all followed it
um the opportunity to put that why into
words makes it no longer simply a
feeling that only you can follow it now
makes it puts into words that a gives
you greater confidence in those
decisions it serves as a filter but more
important is you can share it with other
people so that they understand the
context of why you're making the
decision even though all the data and
advice as we should do the opposite so I
would tell you so I thought about it
because sometimes somehow I thought I
was thinking you will ask me that
question
um I I didn't you yeah you're right
right
but I would tell you though it was uh it
took me some time to answer your
question to your point right because
it's not it's hard it's a hard thing
yeah it's a very simple but hard
question and the answer was really soft
words
as shoes the profession
that I'm in today
I choose to be at PLC for three things
a every day when I come to work
I learned something new
and I become a better person
second thing
I get energy
I don't know how to price energy
it's not making more money less money it
has nothing to do with this I get energy
from all of my colleagues
and the third thing
a very very strong belief
that the future is bright for all of us
that's my way
so that's magical and I'll tell you why
it's magical because it has less to do
with you working at PWC and it has
everything to do with who you are as a
person and I can guarantee you that the
reason your friends love you is because
of that it's not just professional and a
good why isn't just professional it's
who it's the foundation of who you are
and so I and and there's when you say
it's soft as if it's as if you're
apologizing for it I I think it's it's
it's the complete opposite I think it's
a statement of absolute confidence and
it makes you unbelievably beautiful and
appealing to to friends and and
colleagues alike because we know who you
are and what you stand for I think it's
wonderful
thank you
so you know I'm actually blushing but
you can tell
but you're radiating
so what other questions true I've been
asking you what would you like to tell
my colleagues what's in your mind coming
out of kovid not completely out but you
know right the last two years have been
difficult yeah
leadership styles have had to change
yeah or evolved yeah the Millennials
made decisions very differently than
how they made decisions before yeah
why should we pay attention to
I think that we we've become so as a
society especially in business we've
become so obsessed with numbers that we
forgot about people
and the for me there was a magic that
happened when kovitz showed up it was
there was a little bit of real magic
which is when it when we first went into
lockdown which is
almost two years to the day today
when we first went into lockdown
um a lot of leaders whether they were
effective or ineffective prior to covid
a lot of leaders just
sort of leaned on their Humanity they
picked up the phone and called their
team one by one they said are you okay
and they actually cared about the answer
and that's called good leadership
um uh you know and it it was an organic
and human reaction to crisis but I would
have loved to have seen a prior to covet
and I hope that practice remains after
covid you know empathy is a magical
thing and and I think we forget that we
are human beings working with human
beings that's all it is whether they're
colleagues or clients you know it's it's
it is a human Enterprise and and empathy
in the workplace I'll show you what it
looks like because and by the way please
stop saying soft skills we talk about
hard skills and so there's nothing soft
about them number one and number two
hard and softer opposites and I would
hate to think that hard skills and soft
skills are working against each other
it's hard skills and human skills and
for somebody to truly perform I'm going
to teach you hard skills which are the
skills you need to do your job and I'm
going to teach you human skills which
are the skills you need to be a better
human and if you can Master both of
those you will Thrive at this
organization
um and I and I think that we need to
double down on those on those human
skills so what does empathy look like in
the workplace again nothing soft about
it incredibly human so the old system
prior you know a non-empathetic uh
scenario
fairly normal you walk into someone's
office and say um
your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row
um we've had this conversation before
um if you don't pick up your numbers in
the fourth quarter I don't know what's
going to happen right that's a fairly
normal scenario we don't do that here
no amongst your clients yeah
that's good um better
here's what empathy looks like your
numbers are down for the third quarter
in a row we've talked about this before
are you okay what's going on
I'm worried about you
right and
the injection of humanity
in a human Enterprise
pays dividends and this is the thing
that's I think so fascinating about
leadership in general is we actually
don't know the things that we say or do
that actually have an impact positive or
negative I might add you know and
they're moments of Truth like every
single one of us has had an experience
uh
that we've done to someone or someone's
done to us that we thought well that was
so innocuous we didn't even realize that
for example you know somebody did that
somebody asked me how I was how I was
doing they thought nothing of it went
about their day and 10 years later we
still carry that gratitude to that
person and that loyalty
um and and and I think we forget you
know just just how important showing up
and in in our messy imperfect human way
trying to be a version of our best
selves amongst each other every single
day and by the way all the talents and
skills you teach at work about good
leadership the act of listening the how
to have difficult conversations all
these things every single one of those
will translate back home you'll see
marriages the quality of marriages
improve you'll see the quality of
relationships between parents and their
children improved because of the skills
that the the the office is teaching them
how to better you know interact with
clients and colleagues it it's how to
interact with human beings and so all of
the companies that I know that teach
these skills the the number one feedback
they get is my marriage is better and my
relations with my kids is better and you
believe that if there is more of it in
the workforce today
we will be faced with less issues around
people resigning and people going to
other places
I mean yes I mean the great resignation
um I think is
um it's a market correction
you know we know what happens to public
markets when they become unbalanced
right
laws of nature intervene and there is a
correction that's what happens and I
think what we're experiencing is a
massive correction in the labor market
where for too many years uh let's be
honest companies have taken advantage of
their people especially uh low-level
employees because they could and they
actually had attitudes like if you don't
like it here get a job somewhere else
you know
um uh and um and we didn't treat people
as human beings we treated them as line
items disposable line items and the
front lines suffered the most you know
and
um and that balance got more and more
and more tipped and now what we're
experiencing is a great correction we're
now uh
uh
uh labor has much more influence and
says and thanks to covid says I don't
want to be treated this way and I'd
rather have no job than this job now
remember prior to covid fear of the
unknown was enough to keep somebody in
an okay job doesn't mean it was toxic it
was just fine right
um but like who wants to be in a fine
relationship you know I mean a fine job
either like how was work that's fine you
know how's your marriage that's fine
right
um but the fear of the unknown was too
scary why don't you quit I would but I
mean I don't know right and then covet
happened and some people were furloughed
some people lost their jobs some people
didn't lose their jobs but they were
filled with fear
and we made it through
and so all of a sudden the unknown
a lot less scary because I made it and
so when you give me fine and you offer
me unknown I'll take unknown
and I'm really surprised by how many
people are leaving look you're going to
have a small percentage of people who
are leaving because of government checks
that's a very small percentage and that
goes away you have a small percentage of
people who like you know what
I want to be a singer and I want to
follow my dreams we love that right and
that should continue but there's a large
percentage of people saying I just don't
want this
and and I don't even know what I want
but it's definitely not this and they're
choosing the unknown and so I think it's
a huge shot across the bow to most
companies that you've not focused on
culture and Leadership for far too long
and you better fix that because this is
this is kind of an environment of your
making and
um and it's and it affects all ranks as
you know it's not just Junior ranks but
I think it's a great opportunity and
again I think it's an opportunity for
your practice that to help companies who
are concerned about this to double down
on culture and give people a place that
they want to go to work that they feel
seen that they feel heard that they feel
like they have a voice they feel like
their work contributes to something
bigger than themselves that their energy
is not just about helping somebody else
uh make money but rather they get to
share in in the joy and the spoils
um I think it's a huge huge opportunity
for your practice to teach companies how
to do this I think they've you know
you're used to solving business problems
while ignoring cultural problems and
look at look at a lot of the Unicorn you
know whether it's Groupons or or Ubers
or you know or GameStops I mean pick
pick your not game stuff I mean uh Robin
Hood Robin Hood yeah pick your pick your
pick your uh your unicorn
almost every single one of them the
reason things got shaky had nothing to
do with the business model had
everything to do with the leadership and
the culture and the fact that they were
completely ill-prepared for anything
going other than perfectly according to
plan which as it turns out you know no
plan ever goes according to plan I think
it's a huge opportunity for you to
actually change the face of of of how
business Works uh and React to what
companies are we know struggling with
thank you thank you great remark Simon
sign it thank you thank you very much
appreciate it
thank you
thanks
great job man good job
thank you